buzu Bonnie say that thank you and good
afternoon to all of you and thank you
very much for your presence Dominique
and I focused on what needs to be done
in our three work streams number one a
backed-up solution for avoiding our
border and the island of Ireland
number two the other outstanding issues
of the withdrew agreement for instance
the protection of existing geographical
indications amongst others three the
political declaration on our future
relationship our teams will sit together
again tomorrow to try and make progress
last week our teams already at
discussion on island of Ireland and
Northern Ireland as you know we need a
legally operational backstop in the
withdraw agreement
we must find pragmatic solutions in line
with the commitments made by Prime
Minister may in December and March and
we must be dramatize the shoe and spell
out which controls are needed where and
how this should be done next time we
meet
Dominic and I we will take stock on this
work the negotiations are now entering
the final stage we have agreed that you
and the UK will negotiate continuously
from now on and the week and I will meet
regularly to take stock and move the
negotiations forward ladies and
gentlemen the principles of the you in
these negotiations are well known and
have been consistent for the last two
years they have been defined by the you
leaders with a great sense of
responsibility for the European project
and integrity of the single market also
the you respects the choices made by the
UK government we can find common ground
based on the you principles and one and
the other and the choices made by the UK
as I said in July we are more far more
advanced in defining that common ground
for foreign policy and security than for
the economic relationship our challenge
for the coming weeks is to try and
define an ambitious partnership between
the UK and you a partnership that has no
precedent this partnership has to
respect the single market and the
foundations of the European project and
if this is well understood we can
conclude the negotiations successfully
now I give forth on Dominica for
Michelle thank